[Music]
on today's show we talked to a husband
and father who's separated from his wife
and he's just lost we talked to an
extraordinary young woman who is
struggling with immigrant guilt
and we talked to a mom who just found
out something terrible about her
daughter's friend's parents stay tuned
[Music]
yo yo what's up this is john with the dr
john delony's show and i don't know why
we're yelling
you've probably got headphones on or
you're in your car where everything is
volume control to your liking so i don't
know why we're yelling so i'm gonna back
that thing up hey it's good to talk to
you hope you're doing well we have a
packed house out there in the audience
unidos trace cuatro magic four dude
we've increased the audience
participation by a hundred percent it's
good to see everybody we won't put
cameras on you just in case one of y'all
aren't
are cheating on somebody with the
personnel with won't make it weird for
y'all so it's good to see everybody man
um
i hope you're doing well if you're
listening on this show we talk about
mental health relationships everything
if you want to be on it give me a shout
at one eight four four
six nine three thirty two ninety one
it's one eight four four six nine three
three two nine one or go to
johndaloni.com
ask
um a couple of cool things
first
um where do we start here okay so nicole
sends me something on the internets
she um didn't what do you she didn't
slide into my dms she wasn't trying to
date me what do you say it i had she
sent me a direct message is that how you
say it
does that make me sound 100 no but she
sent me a dm but don't snow sliding just
she sent me a dm yeah that's how she
misses normal stuff or something just
don't no sliding what about no did she
snap to me
is that a thing
no
she didn't but i'm just wondering can
you say that or is that you never heard
that so don't say it for snapchatting
that's because you're relatively ancient
i think that's the correct term snaps
snapped me she stopped me is that how
you say that they snap me
oh i don't know i don't do the snapchats
i don't know
whatever you have an active uh oh you're
more of a tick-tock gal huh kelly
no
only because my son's on it oh you are
tick-tock
oh america she comes clean go to uh
kelly at tick tock i hope that's not a
bad thing oh that's probably some random
kelly that is right yeah i don't have an
account but i keep up with it i just
listen to kelly at tick-tock famous
i hope kelly tic-tac makes good choices
because they just got some traffic
so
all right so uh nicole
dude she sent me this and i has had a
thought that i've never had before
um she says i listened to your show from
the beginning and i love it i don't know
if that's one show or all of them i'm
gonna i'm gonna
let's just say one she listened to one
show all the way from the beginning and
she loved it
i don't get emotional or cry i listen
while i'm at work i'm in the middle of
the conversation about the dog from
uh an episode we had a few weeks ago
and had to pause it i'm a mess tears
streaming down my face and the mascara
is gonna have me looking like a raccoon
what is it about when animals
i can't even deal but when it's humans
i'm all good
happens when i watch movies read books
etc i just can't handle it when it comes
to creatures
i
i just right when i got that i had this
thought and
i think it's this so i have a similar
thing like you watch a you know watch
law and order svu or you're eating
popcorn and like grading papers and just
eating pizza and there's all this trauma
on the screen you're like huh well sucks
to be that guy or whatever
but then you watch you know old yeller
or every time i read where the red fern
grows and then i weep for a week
and i think it's this
i think when it comes to like dogs let's
say we assume dogs are a product of
their environment so whenever you see a
dog that's mean or a dog who bites
somebody or dog that doesn't mind we
instantly think man
what kind of crappy owner didn't take
care of business with this dog or what
kind of environment kind of abusive
world we automatically assume
that something happened to this dog
but
when it comes to people
we often blame them for their problems
first and then have to come up with
environments or circumstances second
and i just had an idea
what if we thought about people like we
do dogs
what if
and that sounds backwards tell me if
this sounds crazy kelly cause i'm i'm
thinking this out loud here
but what if when somebody was like a
jerk to me at work my first thought
wasn't oh they're a terrible human but
man i wonder what's going on in their
life that
that is how they thought it was a good
idea to talk to me or if i see someone
who's homeless or somebody who's
struggling or is an addict or someone
who's aggressive or what somebody who's
driving like an idiot on the road if my
first thought wasn't
oh my gosh they are filling the blank if
it but my first thought was man i wonder
what's going on in their world i wonder
what happened to them i wonder who hurt
them i wonder what's going on their
mom's life when
what if i treated people what if we
loved people like we love our dogs does
that sound dramatic i don't know what do
you think ben
i don't think so i think it makes sense
well from this point forward
i'm gonna start treating people like
dogs is that the new slogan of the show
i didn't think through the ending of
this conversation i was just having some
ideas um don't treat people like dogs
maybe
you all know what i'm going at okay and
the second thing
oh we're gonna take an abrupt transition
dude i'm super jazzed the cards are out
so one of the most common questions i
get is this
um so we turned all the screens off to
looney we wrote our letters or whatever
and now my family is sitting around the
coffee table staring at each other and
we don't know what to do next or i
turned all the internets off and my kids
are staring at me and i don't know what
to say or my wife and i just went out or
my boyfriend and i just went out
and we just stare at each other because
we swore we wouldn't talk about covid
and we wouldn't talk about politics
anymore and now we don't have anything
to talk about so we just stare at each
other and staring does not lead to
what right it doesn't so
we created i created some cards and
they're called questions for humans this
is the prototype pack but the new ones
are coming in and they're all rad
and there's no screens they're screen
free there's no questions about politics
there's no questions about covid or
vaccines or anything
they're called questions for human we
have a couple's edition we have a
friends edition and a parents and kids
edition so here's my here's what i
envision
you can get online you can buy one of
them you can buy all three of them in a
pack they're all they're different
colors
you can go on a date you haven't been on
a date in forever you can go on a date
and you can pull a card out and just
talk like a human with the person in
front of you and you can roll your eyes
and be like hey i didn't ask him and
just so we're all clear there's some
very deloney questions here that should
make the table kind of awkward but
you've been wanting to ask the question
anyway and so i just did it for you and
then you can look and be like
sorry it's in the cards we gotta we
gotta answer it right and so i'm helping
you out
and there's also one for friends and so
if you're over the holidays you got
people coming over or you just got a
group of people hanging out
or if you're at one of those churches
that tries to force feed friendships on
each other with small groups whatever
you happen to be
you can pull these cards out you can be
at a bar just hanging out having chips
and salsa and let's have some
conversations and then the one i'm also
super excited about is parents and kids
this is your driving this is y'all are
just sitting around and you're trying to
have less screens it's too cold to go
play baseball whatever go kick a soccer
ball and so here are some questions for
a parent to ask a kid and for kids to
ask their parents back and this is a
cool way for you to tell your kids about
things you did growing up some things
you think about things what scares you
what's fun what makes you laugh
and it's pretty awesome
hey so before i
handed you the deck you gotta mean you
gotta you know what
are you drewing out yeah are we gonna do
it live we're all gonna answer it the
cool thing about this show is it's
edited
so
so well before that i will tell you so
my husband and i went out for his
birthday last week and i took the cards
with us
the prototype deck i did and it was the
first time in i don't know how many
years that we did whoa this is a family
we didn't talk about the kids yeah and
we're in the process of selling our
house and we've been working on it for a
while we didn't talk about the house we
purely talked about the cards and there
was no phones out we had dinner and even
once the food came and i thought well
we'll put them up he was like nope
do another one we went back and forth
and it was awesome how many did you get
through oh we probably got through like
15 or so i keep hearing because we've
been passing them around yeah i keep
hearing people go
and they get through like two of them
yeah
it was like that would lead to something
else and then we talked about something
else and then we'd circle back it was
fabulous i loved it it was great
highly recommend i mean you know been
together 20 years you just sit there
you're talking about the kids all the
time so it was great
okay awesome but to this question you
have to start no i go last nope it's my
show yo hey ben you're filling in for
james you got to go first okay so ben
goes i'll go first yeah i'm down if i
took you to a tattoo parlor right now
whoa and you had to get a tattoo what
would it be
all right no question no hesitation i
would get a space kitten tattoo on my
arm space kitten is the winning band
that i was in last year for battle of
the bands and ramsey solutions it would
be a cat with an astronaut helmet on
have you ever seen the movie frozen
there's a song in that movie actually i
know it's called let it go it's called
let it go
just let
let it go
i would get a high school football
tattooed on my arm
no um yeah i would get a son right on my
lower back like more of like an aztec
son just kidding i wouldn't like a [ __ ]
stamp what would you yeah what would you
get
um so my favorite quote is uh you let
the dogs out who yeah how'd you know
yeah
my favorite quote is a smooth sea never
made a skilled sailor
okay and so i've always if i ever
thought if i got one it would be that
um with because you know for those that
don't know i had breast cancer a couple
years ago that would have kind of end in
the pink ribbon with that so
that's my thought but it hasn't happened
yet so i actually i'm in the process and
so i've got that i've
i have a few and i've got one is my
grandmother used to collect these
porcelain birds that as a kid you're not
allowed to touch but right before she
passed away she like had them saved for
me and so she gave me a cardinal and
then a blue jay and so i've always loved
cardinal and so there's cardinal and my
wife's got
her favorite flowers and so i want to
get like a
half sleeve and with that that stuff in
it so we were already working with some
folks to get that done
they are really proud of tattoos they're
expensive now yeah they were last time i
got them they weren't this expensive
but man i i thought you would get like
my show logo because it's made your life
and career but no
no not so much
this is the gap in your resume that's
going to be hard to explore
i'm just going to tell people i was
talking about some behind the scenes
stuff oh no it was a kelly with an ie
that's right oh man okay so
conversation cards go to johndelani.com
you can get three of them um you can get
the ones for parents and kids one for
friends one for couples this is me
you give me some money and then i'm
gonna save your relationships how about
that awesome good all right let's go to
john in greenville north carolina what's
up brother john how we
hey
doing
for taking my call you got it man thanks
for calling what's up
so i'm calling because i was listening
to your
show a little while ago and you were
talking about a husband that was checked
out and i just really resonated with me
that i feel like that is
definitely where i'm at and that's what
my wife
has complained about as well
why are you checked out man
well see in my opinion i'm not
because i feel like i've been trying
and
my attempts are never
good enough for it to count or
not fast enough there's a million
reasons but so she's telling you that
you're checked out you don't think you
are
[Music]
the crutch okay
is she is she
is she bonkers or she lying or is she
right
you know
exactly that assignment she's right okay
so why are you checked out
so
it's just i don't i don't feel like i'm
ever getting it right so
i mean if i try and do like she wants to
go out i'll plan a date and then
there's some element she'll
pick up on that i missed or it could
have been better and
parks on that one thing and then it
just feels like my attempts aren't going
anywhere so words words like always and
never those are exaggeration and drama
words and they often come up in
relationships and they're just drama so
let's drill down they're never totally
true it's never always or never whatever
so what are a couple of things in your
house that you do really well
so to be honest right now we're actually
separated
hey fun idea lead with that next time
dude
lead with that okay so before you got
separated what were some things that you
did right
so i was doing
wait hold on why are you separated
because we
try to trial separation and
i kind of lied about some things
basically
it started out i was going to school
and i was the one that lied
about
still being in school and i wasn't
okay
then i came clean
and then
i lost some money and didn't
come clean
immediately with it
okay
did you call did you call in a previous
show
no i did not
but i know once i said that i have heard
these themes before okay
so you told your wife you were in school
what'd you do with the money
i was actually trading
trading stocks
yes and you lost because everyone loses
money when they do that
yes and then
then you try to get it back
yeah and it didn't work yeah
and then
i hit it for a while before i told my
wife and
what else were you hiding
nothing anymore that was it
you weren't seeing somebody else
no
bro john
i was not all right
i'll trust you
and so you hid the money you hid this
and then you lied about it and then what
i went to therapy and it just didn't you
don't need to go to therapy if you just
are someone who didn't tell the truth
y'all go to therapy
so to get try to get her
trust back
so therapy was just a move it was like
an roi for you
like i'll do these three things and then
it'll be all all good
that's what i was hoping for sure yeah
did you learn anything about yourself in
therapy
yes what'd you learn definitely
a lot of it
i'm just
very insecure in general and that's
okay a lot of the reason i hide things
that don't come clean
um
i don't know i just had a lot of people
leave in my life so i always have that
fear
that coming
clean
isn't going to push people away or
they're going to say
buzz too much i'm not i'm out
and so you hold it all in you keep
secrets and you don't tell the truth
which
which guarantees they're going to move
away right
yes yeah
so what what ultimately boiled up and
led to the separation
basically i mean she just didn't trust
me like it
a lot of little things
do you lie about a lot of stuff
no okay like the last lie i told
i asked a friend to pick my son up from
daycare because i was running late
and
they told my wife before i did
and so
and i'm talking like an hour
but you didn't tell your wife that you
needed someone to pick up your son
well i did
but she already knew about it
so
so why don't you trust her why don't you
trust your wife
what about her is untrustworthy
uh nothing anymore
really i
i think a lot of what's going on now is
i just didn't see the
need to tell her any earlier because i
was
gonna see her and that's when i saw her
i told her
so how can i help you today man
so
i don't know i
because my therapist kind of run out of
ideas to
help with this is it is there something
you can suggest or is it what do you
want to help with i don't i don't
understand what like when you when you
first called i thought man you can't get
anything right at your house and you
want some help with you know being
engaged at home but you don't even live
there anymore
and then turns out there was some big
secrets and some big deception
um financial infidelities that my buddy
dave calls it um
so i don't know what you i don't know
what you're looking for nothing you've
told me so far would suggest you need
therapy in any way maybe i'm missing
something
sounds like you need to make some firm
life commitments and then go after it
yeah i guess
what do you mean am i missing something
yeah i don't know
i don't know i guess i'm kind of in this
stuck funk where i don't know
what to do next either because
is your marriage over
[Applause]
i don't know i mean i guess that's the
fear i feel that it is
you would know is it over or not
do you have a plan to get back together
are you all talking are you still being
honest with her are you going to get
back together or what
you know whether it's over or not
i want to but she doesn't see how it's
going to happen or
okay
so i didn't ask if are you trying to end
the marriage i'm asking you is it over
she told you this is over
so yeah i guess it is has she filed on
you
no is she going to
she i don't think so i haven't said that
she is let's take a let's take a pause
on that conversation
john
what
do you
want
with your life
with you with your relationship with
your friends answer that question what
just comes to mind what do you want
well i'd like to get back with her no no
no no no no what do you want
that's a thing that's like a i just want
this i want a couch beneath that what do
you want your life to be dude
i've sat i've sat with millionaires i've
sat with single moms
and very few people can answer that
question
like what do you want
i i don't really know i guess
and so
no therapist will be able to help you
because you don't know where you're
going
you keep going to
map makers and
gps app developers
to get you wherever it is you want to go
and you don't know where you want to go
and
you keep going into a hospital for
surgery and they don't
know what you want to do they don't know
what to operate on
and so a question for you the one magic
question in your life john how old are
you
37 37 you get one
one life
and maybe what you're 40 done 50 done
let's say 40. yeah you get one you got
60 left
what do you want
do you want peace do you want happiness
do you want to laugh a whole bunch do
you want to make millions of dollars
what do you want
all the above sounds great okay pick one
like what do you want
i would say happiness is number one
thing okay let's drill down what is
happy just give me two or three pictures
of happy what makes you happy what
brings you joy
taking my son out
um doing what in the tie
i'm going to the pool
i'm not doing that together uh what else
what's another picture of something that
brings you joy
i love tinkering with things okay like
building things uh
and then
i guess hanging out with friends i don't
even care what just being around people
all right
so
the conversation you got to have with
john is
i want to build a life where i'm
surrounded by people i love
i want to have a life where i get to
spend a lot of one-on-one time with my
son
doing things that don't involve my phone
doing things with us
throwing each other around a pool and
laughing and carrying on
and maybe
i want to build a life
with this woman that i had started a
relationship with that i was married to
we have kids together
and i screwed it up and i'm going to
start there
because right now you're in response
mode you're in defense mode
think about a basketball team that never
shoots the ball all they do is play
defense and every time you
get a turnover you just roll it back to
the other team
because you don't even know how to shoot
you know where the basket is
yeah
and so
right now you're trying to win her back
or what are the four things i need to do
to make her trust me again
and if there's any hope of salvaging
this relationship it's you taking her
out one more time and sitting down and
saying
oh my i was wrong
now i didn't get it before i was trying
to do things to make you like me or i
was trying to do enough so that you
wouldn't
nag me or complain
and i missed it
what i should have been doing
is being with you and loving you and
that other crap dishwasher stuff takes
care of itself you just do the dishes
because
it honors somebody that you love and you
want their life to be better and easier
and hopefully they're that's reciprocal
otherwise it gets into a contest of i
want you to take me out well then i'm
going to plan an outing well that outing
wasn't good enough well then the next
then you get into this you're it's a
competition it's a game
it's a waste of your life
love isn't a tennis match or a soccer
game man
am i right am i on to something
oh yeah definitely
okay
so remember this behavior is a language
and you people could talk all they want
i don't care what they're saying i want
to see how you treat people i want to
see how you interact with somebody how
you love somebody how you walk home and
say hey how can i honor you today
that's different then i did the dishes
right
right and then you've got to be honest
with john you've got to be honest and
say here's where i want to go
and then a counselor or a coach
can help you get wherever it is you want
to go
but you got to choose brother to i don't
want
a
life of me i want my life to be wheels
off
i can tell you in my own life it was i
want to make this much money and i want
to have this job title i was that
specific and i realized what an
obnoxious
waste of my one tiny
little bitty precious life
i then changed it to dude i want to be
surrounded by people that i love i want
to do work that matters
to me and to the people that um are
involved in it
and i have a skill of sitting with
people when the wheels are falling off
their life and i'm gonna do that whether
i'm working at burger king or whether
i'm on the radio whether i'm a counselor
wherever that happens to be i'm gonna
sit with hurting people
and then strangely
oh by the way i'm gonna work real real
real hard real early in the morning
until real late at night for a day after
week after month after year and then
what you'll find is when those things
line up money takes care of itself and
titles take care of themself but you
gotta decide where you're going first
and what you're doing john is trying to
get everybody else to tell you what your
life needs to look like and that's a
recipe for
depression that's a recipe for a black
hole like an energy and joy suck of just
a bottomless pit
because nobody can fill that hole only
you can
so you said it
you want to be surrounded by people you
love you want that woman to love you and
you want to love her and and
start with that one precious question my
brother what do you want and then
go
get it
we'll be right back on the dr john de
luna show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show
the world is bonkers right we all know
this and one of the most common
questions i get is how do i find a
counselor in the chaos i've reached out
and there's a six month waiting list or
i can't afford it or they only take
insurance or i can't get off work and
time to go see somebody it's way across
town what do i do because i want help
with my anxiety my depression my
relationships are hanging on by a thread
i want to be a better mom i gotta
process this trauma that happened to me
when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john delaney show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right let's go to sandy in grand
rapids michigan what's up sandy
hi say john how are you i'm so good how
about you
good thank you so what's up
um i wanted to ask you um how can i deal
with the guilt that i carry uh as a
child of immigrants
who unpack that for me that one's a good
one
yeah so my parents fled the middle east
once the wars started
and after jerusalem moving around we
finally came to america as refugees back
when i was about eight years old how
long ago was that 10 years ago 15 years
ago um
about 13 13. okay
oh can i guess here can i guess
sure
so
you how old you were 13 when you moved
here
i i was eight when i was eight oh you
said that okay so
you get dropped into an american school
and there's a
you got trapped between cultures is that
right
100 yes and then
parents are still in fight or flight
because their home was taken from them
and the easiest thing someone in fight
or flight can do is to default hardcore
to what you know and what is safe and
what is safe is
this is the way we do it because this is
how we have always done it
you're spot on and then you're an
immigrant student who now wants to go to
college if you're not are you in college
or through
i am in college my last year oh and now
you're tortured by i love the idea in
america you can kind of just do whatever
you want to whenever you want to however
you want to
and i also love and want to honor my
parents and oh crap what i do now
is that right you got it you got it
exactly right kelly we should start a
radio show it's incredible
uh hey um so iraq is that right
yes okay what um
what religious sect
uh christian okay okay
so
oh man
how fun is that
i've been finding at church as a hoot is
that has that just been a blast
holy
so how do you deal with how do you deal
with the guilt um tell me more about
that
well you know growing up i heard all
these awful stories about what they've
been through and then hearing comments
like we get out so much to give you and
you know your siblings a better life so
that's you know all that pressure
um and like you said they have very
strict views and they're very stuck on
their old ways
so you know i did the right thing by
like going to college and getting
education getting like a stable
corporate job doing all that kind of
stuff
um and most of it is signed but what's
really hard for me has been when i don't
agree on like certain topics there are
certain views um like not moving down
until i'm married no matter how old that
is
dating only within the community the
same religion same you know country
um and then like being trained from
birth as a girl to take care of the
house
cook and clean that kind of thing while
my brothers you know got to sit around
and have fun yeah just things like that
just things like that that was the most
incredibly dismissive just like just
things like that like my
like my
gender and my work ethic and my
religious heritage and my my romantic
life just little things like that
oh man that's so hard so hard
um
wow and so you're about to graduate and
this is about to get real for you do you
live at home now
i do okay
and do you enjoy living at home or is it
are you dying a slow miserable death
of the latter okay
and walk me through
like just if for the average american
listener who doesn't understand this
it feels like a simple answer and by the
way i want you to know
um i've worked with a number of
international students and immigrant
students over the years and so your
journey is one i've heard a lot
um but i did contact kelly let me know
that this call's coming so i did contact
two of my buddies who are professors who
study this intercultural competence it's
that's a challenge for folks like you
who are caught between two two worlds um
and that's so hard um so
the
walk an average american listener
through because it seems like we'll just
move out of the house dude
like
when you hear something like that your
buddy in school just like well just move
out walk somebody through what that
actually would mean for you
um
that would mean i would bring so much
shame to my family i wouldn't hear the
end of it um most likely if i were to do
that then my sister will kind of get
like a bad reputation and like she won't
get married um i'll probably kind of be
shunned from the community
um
just you know
things like that besides shame and
shumming i mean
shame and shunning what else sandy
um lots of anger they probably will not
talk to me for
years if not even if ever
um i probably won't get any support with
that
the financial support
right yeah so or emotional mental yeah
all of it yeah
so it's it's it's kind of it's an opt-in
or opt completely out huh
exactly yeah
so what are a couple of things that you
love
about the your parents culture your
culture that your parents are really
holding on to tightly what's a couple
things you love
um the support from family is pretty
major um you won't really ever be in
need financially or like that when you
have them um without any question
they'll be there to help you
and
even though you know we moved out from
home um they kind of built a new home
here the
the culture definitely came with them
and the people are still kind of
together they help each other out is
there a small iraqi community that still
hangs out
yeah yeah and then there's moms and dads
talk about who's gonna marry who and
when and all that
yep
um
so
i'm gonna give you a complex answer okay
and here's here's why it's complex
i don't feel qualified to give you an
answer that's not gonna be heavily
directed by
the fact that i'm like
an american male
does that make sense
so the easy answer is
um
at the end of the day you have to make a
choice
and at the end of the day you know
there's not an easy exit strategy and
there's not an easy acceptance strategy
and
at the end of the day it's simple to be
like well you just got to move on cut
your ties and go
and whoa you're talking hundreds if not
thousands of years of this is how and
why we love one another it's different
right it's it's hard and it's messy
and so
the reality is you're gonna have to make
a choice i i don't feel comfortable
telling you what here's what i think
your choice should be
what i will tell you is
here are some broad parameters
uh or some broad things to think through
and again there's a couple of my buddies
who are researchers that walk me through
this
um
the first one is no matter what you do
make peace with conflict because it's
gonna come
there's not a choice you make that
doesn't come with conflict here whether
it's internal or whether it's external
so if you make peace with conflict it's
often not
you can hold it in your soul better
meaning
it's people that go to the gym to work
out that realize working out's hard and
they quit
it's those that know working out is
really hard and that's why i'm going
that do really well does that make sense
yeah so expect that conflict
especially in a family system where
somebody decides they're going to change
the rules of the system um
has there been any sort of what i would
call family concession meaning is there
a few things that they don't really like
to admit but that they've americanized
yeah um but i feel like it's more so
with the boys in the family they've said
you know them going out them dating them
that kind of thing and it's definitely
just around the girls
so is there somebody in your family
system um is it a highly paternal system
like you don't ask questions you just
say yes sir and y'all move on
yeah or is there a conversation you can
have with mom or with that is there a is
there that level of
um
just mutual respect
um i can definitely have a conversant
with my dad um it at the end of it it
does kind of end up in that hole like
i'm the dad see what i do kind of thing
but he will listen out
um just he just kind of tells me that
it's out of his control and messes out
of society it measures how the community
is and i have to just like live with it
basically oh so he really passes the
buck on to not this is what i say but
sorry this is just the world we live in
and that's just kind of where that is
so let me ask you a hard question i know
you've thought about it what do you want
to do
what do you want to do
you asked me how to deal with guilt
that that
provides a hint that you may just be
thinking of graduating and going to
getting your own place and figuring this
thing out
that has definitely been my
thought for a while and i'll i'll think
it and then you know with any anger
like we'll fuel it and then that kind of
goes away and then the guilt comes in oh
i gave up so much i shouldn't do that
um but i don't think i can see myself
being happy if i do stay so what i will
tell you is guilt will ultimately
kill you
from the inside out
it'll melt your spirit and it will
literally eat you physiologically
and so what i will tell you is
either
choose to
choose to live into your culture
or choose to
chart your new path
and you're going to feel sad it's going
to be chaotic there's going to be
conflict either way you go
but if you lean into and let guilt
become the the the blood that circulates
through your veins
man that's gonna be it's gonna just it's
gonna destroy you from inside out
my hope and dream would be
that you sit down with your dad and say
um i am so grateful for the heritage i'm
so grateful for the culture i'm so
grateful for the community and
i feel like i need to go find myself
in my hope and prayer for me and my
family
is that you all don't respond to my
choice
by ending our relationship and cutting
me off
because here's the other the other side
of choice you can't control other
people's response
and so whatever choice you make
in or out
they get to choose their response and so
if they choose to cut you off if they
choose to withdraw all support if they
choose to
shame you and whatever whatever they
choose to do
um
whatever that community chooses to do
that's their response to you not the
other way around does that make sense
yeah and so you said what are you
studying
accounting
and what do you want to do when you grow
up an accountant or you want to work for
a company just doing books and things
um i'm currently working for a company
doing that um the hopes is yeah get a
master's degree and become an accountant
okay
so where do you want to do that
what do i do accounting
where are you set where
i haven't thought that far to be honest
with you
so do this get a friend or two friends
and think about
what tomorrow could look like go one
year go three years down the road
imagine yourself done with grad school
imagine yourself
walking across the stage
and then what and i want you to be
really clear about what a picture of
then what looks like what state are you
living in what does your house look like
what does your home look like what do
your friends and community look like
paint that picture
because i want you to walk towards
something whatever you do not run from
something i want you to if you're going
to lean into
this like you know what i need to go
back home until i'm married that's the
culture that's our that's our
um national
culture that's our religious culture
that's the heritage
um i'm gonna honor my family that way
and i'm gonna honor myself that way by
honoring my family that whatever you
choose to do
i'm gonna go towards that or
nope this is the part where i carve my
own path i'm going to choose that i'm
going to lean into it and here's what
it's going to look like and that way
you're walking towards something and
you're not
untethered and unanchored because
there's gonna be conflict when you
disrupt the system
but my recommendation is sit down with
dad it sounds like he's an awesome guy
that would listen to you and sit down
and say
i know these things and
i've got to chart my own path i've got
to take my own course and i hope that
you won't choose that that means
that we're done
hope that you choose not to
cut me off to shame me to disconnect
from me but you choose you can be
disappointed you can say that's not the
path i would have chosen but that's my
girl she's brilliant she's accomplished
and we're gonna support her even if we
have to grit our teeth
and he may say sorry that's out of my
control it's out of my hands
and then he's made his decision
but at the end of the day um i can't
speak into it for you i can't tell you
what i think you should do or here's
what i would do because i don't know
i can know i've made different choices
than my parents probably would have
picked for me
but i also know that um they trained me
from a young boy to man here's a machete
here's how this works you go carve your
own path and so i was blessed and
fortunate that way
um
thank you so so much for the call here's
what i would love i would love to know
how that conversation goes if you'll
circle back to us and let us know how it
goes
um
i always say this
choose guilt not resentment
if you're going to go home and you're
going to live in ash and you're going to
just smolder from the inside out and
that's gonna that's gonna burn down your
relationships and your friendships and
your community connections and your
faith and your relationship with your
mom your dad your brothers
choose guilt over resentment every time
and don't let people beat you up before
we chose we did this and i want to say
like well y'all chose that
and be grateful to
it's a hard hard road you're walking
expect conflict expect this comfort get
some people that are going to walk it
with you
and go towards something not away from
it we'll be right back this is doctor
john delaney
one of the most common questions folks
ask me is what they should do when
anxiety or panic strikes like a
lightning bolt i've been helping folks
101 for years but i wanted to create
something that everyone could use
anywhere at any time so i created a free
guided meditation it's not really a
meditation but really me just walking
with you through your anxiety alarms
from start to finish i'll guide you
through a breathing exercise and show
you how to lean in listen and head
towards healing it is free and it's for
everyone you can download this guided
meditation today for free at
johndaloni.com
all right we are back let's take one
more let's go to melissa in saint joe mo
what's up melissa how are you doing
oh not too shabby how are you doing
same not too i'm going to start can i
steal that from you not too shy
absolutely yes all right not too shabby
melissa what's up
so i stumbled upon some information um
the other day that kind of now has me in
a quandary so um
what'd you stumble on
so i was looking online i was showing um
one of my friends
online where you can look up
registered sex offenders
and saw a familiar face
my
daughter's best friend's dad
is on this list oh crap
yeah she there's seven
um
so i
of course did some googling digging and
basically the
he was 22
talking online with what he thought was
a 14 year old girl that ended up being a
cop
yeah so and
still went to meet like at the wendy's
or whatever and got busted
um it was in 2007 so i mean it's been
a long time and i haven't seen anything
since then like online it basically says
that
you know he's in good standing or
whatever
um
i also know well i also i have a social
work background so i know the recidivism
rates and things like that are what
though
are horrible
horrible and just so in case people
don't know what the word recidivism
means what does that mean
it means that they do it again the
chance of them doing again is a
bazillion percent right
so
i don't want to punish the child for the
sins of the father but i also obviously
need to protect my daughter
um so you are not punishing anybody
dad is
you are
not punishing anybody
at all
what's the quandary here
i have a six-year-old almost almost
six-year-old daughter so we're in this
like i'm trying to put myself in your
shoes
and my blood is boiling it's like what's
the what's the what's the quandary
basically like
just to completely cut ties or just
because i have no idea this we don't
know the family all that well i i really
like mom i've rarely ever spoken to dad
um
and like my husband even brought up what
if she doesn't know and i'm like
am i i assumed that she knew but i mean
who knows so
just
you know just start ignoring
calls or just say look i found this out
so we're done
set you know do some safety planning and
say look she can come to my house but
we're not going to your house or you
know like just what
because like i have a social work
background i've helped people safety
plan but it's different when it's your
kid it is it is it is and so i am so
i'll tell you a quick story
i won't tell you a quick story that
would take too long because i always say
i'll tell you a quick story then it's
like 45 minutes later and kelly's passed
out of sleep on the control board over
there
what i'll tell you is i've been in a
couple situations like in a crisis
response
or i'm looking and thinking huh
i probably i don't know what's going on
here
and then somebody one of my partners
will roll up and be like what are you
doing call 9-1-1 or get the you know
what i mean so like you get so close to
it
that you you lose perspective
right and so what i will tell you
is the last person
on the planet i would allow my daughter
to be in proximity to is a registered
sex offender with a history of preying
on young women young girls right right
agreed
with an exclamation point at the end of
that sentence
so
everything you choose to do after that
is in service to
my daughter will never be around a known
sex offender if i have any breath in my
lungs period
and so whether you choose to sit down
with wife
and say
here's the deal i learned this i know
our daughters are friends i don't care
what story y'all are going to give me
there can be no
possible way my daughter is in your home
is in a car with you y'all i mean
you can do that that would be the a plus
hyper integris
gentle direct but loving way to say
i learned new information and the
relationship between us and our kids is
different
or
man there's seven and the world gets
busy things get bananas do they live
across the street from you they down the
road i mean
pretty much
so
they actually they used to go to the
same school then covet hit and things
change so they don't actually go to the
same school anymore
um but
that was her her close friend from that
school and we've continued to have play
dates and things like that
and then to add another layer of like
weirdness and ick is so we
basically joined a particular chapter of
a local community group that's based
around kids because that family is in
this chapter
dude
he's not allowed to be around kids
so yeah i don't know what all the
i'm telling populations are he doesn't
get to be around kids
and if there is some sort of way they
finagled themselves around a lot of kids
i would throw every flag on planet earth
i would turn on every light and hit
every siren
i'd call every probation officer i could
that's that's i mean that's your job as
a community member
or to go directly to them
and ask wife
your husband is a registered sex
offender and best i can tell
he was preying on a young girl and went
to meet her
how are y'all involved in a local
community group that's revolved around
children
walk me through how this works
that's the kind of i'm confrontational
in that way my wife is especially
um
but
yeah this one's bigger than even your
kid that's not a complicating factor
that is like a gasoline on a fire factor
and so you've heard me say this before
on the show and i'll say it again not by
your hand but in your lap
this isn't your fault this isn't
something that you caused or sought out
well you did when you started googling
but it dropped in your lap and thank god
it did that it happened to drop in the
lap of a social worker
who knows how incredibly damaging this
thing can be
and
man this has all you know i just saying
it out loud you know this has all the
makings of oh no
right
yes
like and then when you found out oh
they're in this group and then oh my oh
my like the puzzle pieces start going
together even if it's totally innocent
the snowball just started rolling yes
so what i'm telling you
and i'm putting you in an unfair
position but i didn't do it the cosmos
did it i'm just calling it
you out to say
everything
as loud as you can
whether that's looking up the probation
officer whether that's calling your
local
police department to get some more
information
whether that's notifying the
the umbrella agency of this community
group
whether that's going directly to their
home
and saying my daughter has been in your
house
what in the
y'all didn't tell us
how and how in the world
yeah i
again
friends will come and go your daughter's
seven she's gonna have a million friends
you're gonna break up with half of them
the other half's gonna move away i think
you know i mean that's life
just imagine yours
your daughter's life
three years from now you say no it's
fine it was a long time ago 10 years ago
he seems fine
and something is nefarious is going on
i'd never forgive myself
yeah and that's just you thinking about
you i'm thinking about your daughter
like what's our one job as parents keep
our kids safe
absolutely not to protect them from all
the harm i mean from stubbing their toes
and falling down and getting f's i'm all
about that
but this one
we got one job on this one
so what's your next move melissa and
again i'm walking alongside you because
i know you're so far in this
it's like oh no
and it is that big
but the world needs melissa's to turn
all the lights on and say no no no no
not on my watch not my daughter not my
neighborhood not my daughter's friends
cause my daughter is everybody's
daughter and everybody's daughter's my
daughter and i'm calling this one out
so what's your next move what's what are
you gonna do today
um well i mean i can definitely look
into you know who
whoever is providing supervision over
the whole thing and
i like i said to try to figure out with
our family like okay do we say
you know she can come here but that's it
or just completely cutting ties is
basically where i'm at like which
because it's cutting ties is doable
especially since they don't even attend
the same school anymore that like
okay so that's that's like part one a d
like way down the list
that's solving little problem
well and getting into i obviously yeah i
have no problem with getting in touch
with the community organization in
question and making sure that
even if you call and say my daughter's a
part of this group and you have a
registered sex offender as a leader in
this group or a part of this group what
are you doing
yeah
well and i'm
i mean you know what to do and you
assume my assumption is they
i had no clue and i've known these
people longer than this community group
has
so
i'm assuming they're going to go
holy crap
yeah because i am and i don't i don't
even know what community i had no
i had no clue
how long have you known them
three years
do you have a good enough relationship
with that wife just to call and say this
is mom to mom what in the world what the
crap
can you do that
i mean i could do it i don't know that i
would like she's not a close friend by
any stretch of the imagination we text
when we're getting the girls together
but that's about the extent of it but
you're not going to say anything are you
oh no
i know you don't know me but i'm not i'm
an ad advocate at heart like that's i
i'm just trying to make figure out
whether it's better just to completely
just to basically
throw gas in the fire throw the bomb
walk away
say this is not okay and just cut ties
and then have to explain it to my
daughter when she's older
or
whether it would be at all feasible for
you know playdates just at my house or
something like that so like i said i i
feel bad for his daughter because it's
not her fault but that's not your
problem to solve
that's th that's a bed that he created
your job is not to create a fun
environment for his daughter
that's that's that's
that is the situation they're gonna have
to handle you're trying to control too
much
i i feel bad for his daughter too i'm
brokenhearted for her i am devastated
for her
because this is gonna happen over and
over in her life
that she's going to make close friends
and then it's going to get out
and then they're going to be a mess i
can't imagine they're allowed to have
other kids too at their house
well in the day that i found this out
she had my daughter had spent basically
the whole afternoon with their family on
that like two days before that
have you done a
have you done a forensic interview on
your daughter
yes
and she's okay
well dad was it was just
friend siblings mom out riding bikes dad
was at work so he wasn't even
around
so just to cut to it if this is my
daughter yes this relationship is over
until further notice period full stop
conversation's over
and if um
again i'm gonna make that call and say
hey can we meet out and just meet out in
the front yard for a minute
um
i want to make sure everything's okay
i'll make sure my daughter y'all didn't
hurt my daughter and i'm upset that
you didn't disclose this
when my daughter started coming to your
house and i found out about it this way
they had a responsibility to tell you if
this is hanging over you know what i
mean so think about it this way if i got
arrested for stealing money and it was
10 years ago
and then i'm getting a job with somebody
i need to say hey by the way this is in
my background here's what actually
happened here's the truth of the last 10
years and here's who i am and where i am
now
i have a moral and ethical obligation to
put that out there
and if you're on the sex offender
registry list for soliciting young girls
and then going to try to visit with them
and thank god it was a cop and not an
actual 14 year old
right and
then my seven-year-old just starts going
to play at your house oh
no
no oh no no
and you're gonna join a community group
that's got a lot of kids around
no
dude i'm calling including including 14
year old girls no
no
no
something's not right here i can't
imagine somebody's that brazen except
people are
yeah unbelievable yes every single alarm
goes off
conversation's over
either have the conversation with her
i'm calling the community group today
today
if mom texts and says hey we haven't
seen you in a while
um can so and so come and play and you
write back no she can't come play today
thank you so much
and she says hey is there a problem say
hey yeah let's chat if she invites you
in great
but this is your moment well let's say
you've been an advocate and a lot of
advocacy these days happens on the
internet or a lot of advocacy happens
like going to like um like fundraisers
and things
this is advocacy right now
you got to go through me to get to my
daughter and these kids in this
neighborhood you got to go through me
and my
husband and my team and my profession
because ad real advocacy costs us
something cause it can get us hurt real
advocacy is a pain and it it comes at a
cost and this is your moment melissa to
stand up for your daughter for all the
daughters
and for god almighty dude
sheesh
thanks for the call melissa do it do it
hey
you owe us now
after you make your calls i want you to
let us know how it goes call back to the
show and let us know
man man man kelly i'm having a good
attitude huh
i haven't said any bad words i haven't
walked off we've set a few in here
dude
imagine this america i'm speechless
this is a rare moment
i'd like to welcome everybody
to the moment of speechlessness
ah as we wrap up today's song
ben brought one in
i can't use it man i gotta i gotta pivot
you're welcome wait you're pivoting i
got to i can't
that's disappointing it is
but i haven't done the show long enough
i don't have like i'll get cancelled
i just will i just will
i think the ratings will go up
yeah everyone wants to come see the
house on fire yes for sure
ah this is actually one of my favorite
songs it's by the killers it's called
human and it goes like this i did my
best to notice when the call came down
the line
up to the platform of surrender i was
brought but i was kind and sometimes i
get nervous when i see an open door
close your eyes clear your heart cut the
cord are we human
or are we dancing
i don't even know about that last call
yo
whoo
right here on the dr john de luna show
[Music]